This is very, very interesting. President
Joe Biden is currently experiencing
the highest initial approval rating of any
president dating back 28 years to Bill Clinton
in 1993. The All America Economic Survey has found
that Joe Biden has a 62 percent approval rating
right now. His initial approval rating that beats
the first presidential rating of Barack Obama, of
George W. Bush, of Bill Clinton, and, of course,
of Donald Trump. And in fact, Joe Biden's initial
rating of 62 percent approval is 18 points higher
than that of Donald Trump. There are a number
of takeaways here. First of all, when we look at
these numbers and understand that there are hyper
partizan enclaves of Americans that will either
always approve or always disapprove of a president
merely based on political party, you realize
that the real range, it's not really zero to 100,
it's probably more like, I don't know, 20 to 80
or twenty five to seventy five or whatever. So
when you see a rating of 36, that is much
closer to the bottom than it would seem
because some portion will always approve of
the president. When you see a number like 62,
that's much closer to the top because because some
portion will always disapprove. So, number one,
the difference between 62 and 36 is much
bigger than merely the difference between
the two numbers. When you understand American
politics, that's number one. Number two,
important takeaway is that this really reinforces
that Donald Trump could have easily won reelection
if back in March he had simply said this
is serious, the doctors know what to do.
Let's do what they say. Oh, they say wear masks.
We are printing American flag masks, do the
patriotic thing. If Trump and his staffers were
regularly pictured from the beginning with the
patriotic American flag masks, I know that might
violate flag code. OK, don't email me about that.
Donald Trump would have sailed to reelection,
as we saw so many world leaders do, who dealt
with the virus. Well, and that is confirmed by
this polling. Much of Joe Biden's early approval
is based on his handling of the coronavirus on
which he has a nearly 70 percent approval rating.
So Trump could be president right now, and it's
because of Trump that he is not. We'll continue
to follow Joe Biden's approval. It could go up.
It could go down. I really don't know. These are
unique circumstances in which we find ourselves.
But I want to hear from you. Where do you believe
Joe Biden's approval will go and or does it depend
on accomplishing something like, for example,
getting the covid relief checks to Americans?
I believe if he fails to do it,
it will be a political disaster, but I do
believe he is going to do it. Let me know
your thoughts. I'm on Twitter at David Pakman,
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman dot com.